hello ken haley byron daniel laura this  is the nickel fellowship committee you  are a 2021 nickel fellow hang on can you  say that again  wow guys thank you okay great so it's  good  thank you so much oh my god i am  enormously happy what an accomplishment  i really enjoyed reading your script you  read it i loved your script i'm super  psyched to talk about that let's just  say you're the director it really comes  down to three things hard work uh luck  and talent thank you so much truly that  just happened  that was so enjoyable to explore the  writing process it has felt all the way  along like a welcoming environment we  all start somewhere it's helped me have  full confidence in myself i get to write  every day there's nothing that can stop  me from doing that to get this sort of  recognition just made it also worth it